[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 1er décembre 2016
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition du journal préparé par
la rédaction voici les principaux titres
journée de lutte contre le sida nous
irons au lycée emilie de breteuil à
montigny le bretonneux où les élèves se
sont mobilisés et ce chiffre 24 % des 15
25 ans déclarent ne pas avoir peur du
sida économie également avec le simi le
salon de l'immobilier d'entreprise qui
se déroule en ce moment un rendez vous
d'affaires importants ou s'impliquent
saint quentin en yvelines et ce week end
à trappes va se dérouler une battle de
hip hop elle les compétiteurs répètent
activement rencontre en fin de journal
avec est l'un d'entre eux il est
emprunté chaque jour par des centaines
de véhicules le pont schuller qui relie
maurepas à la verrière et qui permet
d'accéder à la guerre va faire l'objet
d'importants travaux le pont sera doublé
alors d'un chantier en deux phases la
première débutera en janvier 2010 est
dans les prochaines semaines coût total
plus de neuf millions d'euros financés
par l'état la région ou encore à
l'agglomération
c'est aujourd'hui nous en parlions en
titre la journée mondiale de lutte
contre le sida cent cinquante mille
personnes vivent avec le vih en france
et fait particulièrement inquiétant les
plus jeunes ne sont plus effrayés par la
maladie nous sommes allés au lycée
emilie de breteuil à montigny le
bretonneux rencontrer des élèves qui
avaient choisi de se mobiliser autour de
leurs enseignants n icolas d'andry le
préservatif féminin n'est pas en latex
info effectivement il est pas en latex
il est en nitrile est ce qui fait que
quand il ya une personne car des
problèmes d'allergie il ya quelques
jeunes qui ont des problèmes d'allergie
au latex
on peut utiliser un préservatif féminin
il n'y a pas de risque d'allergie
sensibiliser sur le vih à travers un
quiz c'est l'initiative proposée par le
lycée emilie de breteuil de montigny le
bretonneux pour la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida notamment à travers
un stand d'information c'est de prévenir
les jeunes contre la maladie du sida
les élèves de seconde ont déjà eu
l'occasion d'avoir une intervention un
qui s'appelle les après-midi du zapping
nous avons installé des distributeurs de
préservatifs à plusieurs endroits dans
l'établissement le sida touche
énormément de personnes dans le monde et
je pense que c'est un sujet qui doit
être abordée même au sein de l'éducation
nationale
accompagné du pôle jeunesse de la mairie
de montigny le bretonneux plusieurs
thématiques sont abordées transmission
du sida mode de protection et
information sur la sexualité des sujets
qui attise la curiosité des lycéens sur
les modes de transmission à ya encore
beaucoup d'idées reçues et par exemple
sur le fait que les moustiques peuvent
transmettre le vih
évidemment est faux ou encore sur le
fait qu'on peut attraper le sida en
s'embrassant sur la bouche le
préservatif reste le meilleur moyen de
se protéger des études sont en cours
pour découvrir un vaccin en france entre
35000 et 50000 personnes ignoreraient
leur infection par le virus du sida
sentait toujours et la demande de
l'agencé nationale de la sécurité du
médicament à la société yvelinoise quart
matt de suspendre toutes les
implantations de coeur artificiel chez
des patients après le décès d'un
cinquième patients greffés en octobre
c'est donc à un coup dur pour cette
entreprise basée à vélizy et qui a perdu
en quelques heures 26 9% en bourse car
matt qui assure que le coeur artificiel
n'est pas en cause dans ce dernier décès
de nouvelles analyses doivent avoir lieu
avant la reprise possible ou non des
essais économie le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise il se déroule en ce moment
jusqu'au vendredi 2 décembre porte
maillot à paris saint quentin en
yvelines exposé au sein de l'espace
paris saclay ses nombreux projets
d'immeubles de bureaux d'activité c'est
un moment particulièrement important qui
permet aux investisseurs de découvrir lé
force d'un territoire haussmann vendeur
n'est l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines versailles grand parc et
paris saclay tous réunis ici
même stand à l'occasion du salon de
l'immobilier d'entreprise
le but attirer les investisseurs le but
est de faire partager au plus grand
nombre pour que nous les investisseurs
est immédiatement envie de s'installer
sur paris saclay et plus principalement
sur race à grands pas là nous c'est un
moyen aux vecteurs de communication des
changes
et puis en trois jours en fait on peut
largement optimisé ce rendez vous tous
les territoires franciliens sont
présents aussi mis pour michèle losier
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son agglomération a toute sa place au
sein du simi grâce aux forces qu'elles
possèdent les forces de 50 ha déjà c'est
que
d'agglomération qui existent et qui a
beaucoup de qualités
ouvrables elles 235 mille habitants et
140 chalets l'emploi 16600 crise est
surpris donc soit l'issue d'une vie
nouvelle et dort depuis
plus de quarante ans de construisons à
saint-quentin dont nous savons ce que
c'est que l'aménagement et donc les
promoteurs qui sont là
bien sûr toujours intéressé par d'autres
territoires
il reste que attractif ils savent plus
ce qu'ils ont à faire
vraiment à des personnes qui maîtrisent
bien les choses c'est la première fois
que l'agglomération de paris-saclay
participent à l'événement le simi est
donc un enjeu important pour eux il
souhaite faire découvrir leurs projets
j'ai entendu parler du plateau de saclay
qu'un projet aux majeurs structurantes
mais découdre sur notre sens d autres
opportunités puisque nous avons une
soixantaine de zones d'activités
économiques à l'échelle du territoire
donc il ya un rôle majeur figurants mia
que ce qui est autour qui offre des
capacités
sur un territoire étendu avec des
capacités pour accueillir les petites
entreprises
l'artisanat la pme qui par définition
est également les grands comptes
plusieurs conférences sont à prévoir
lors du simi l'événement ferme ses
portes le vendredi 2 décembre 2016
ce matin à la verrine à la mairie de
versailles 20 jeunes recrues de l'armée
de terre en dhr hawks signé un contrat
d'engagement c'est une signature
symbolique et qui clôt cette année de
recrutement nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ces futurs soldats à
camille lambert
ils ont une vingtaine d'années et ont
fait le choix de dédier leur vie à leur
pays jeudi 1er décembre ses vingt jeunes
recrues ont signé leur engagement au
sein de l'armée de terre une évidence
pour maximilien qui rejoint le 4e
régiment de chasseurs de gap
c'était un rêve depuis l'objet depuis
l'âge de 7-8 ans je voulais je voulais
m'engager à l'armée l'art mais pour moi
c'est vraiment un métier où
c'est la seul métier où on est vraiment
solidaire avoir un esprit de groupe
c'est ça que je recherchais déjà dans un
métier et puis voilà faire le grand pas
déjà mon père il voulait être engagée là
pas pu suivre un peu les traces de la
famille c'est ça si lille a toujours
voulu rendre service had à tout le monde
il aime bien et puis un jeu truqué les
miens je vous rappelle tout ce qu'il
touche de sport il ya c'est donc là
dedans il va pouvoir s'en donner à coeur
joie ce mois de décembre l'armée de
terre a engagé près de 1200 jeunes dans
l'hexagone ils deviendront combattants
de chars mécanicien même sapeurs
pompiers comme raphaël je voulais un
média ou mais du sens et on fasse
quelque chose d'utile go et après il ya
aussi le côté c'est un métier qui est
dehors
un médian on bouge beaucoup et c'est le
sport je vais pas un métier en soi dans
un bureau on est dans une dimension de
vocation est en fait l'armée de terre a
réussi son pari de recruter quinze mille
personnes sur l'échéance 2016 avec un
chiffre près similaires sont 2017 et
nous tenons deux chiffres les jeunes
gens qui viennent nous voir sont
effectivement arrivées réelle vocation
du service de l'état et du service de la
france
cette signature en mairie de versailles
a clos cette année de recrutement les
nouvelles recrues vont maintenant suivre
une formation militaire parmi les 120
spécialités proposées dans l'armée
culture à présent le compte ce récit
ancestrale est à l'honneur à saint
quentin en yvelines le réseau des
médiathèques de l'agglomération organise
la 16e édition de la fête du conte
jusqu'au 10 décembre des instances sont
consacrés à ces récits à vivre entre
amis ou en famille cette année la
marraine s'appelle nathalie leone c'est
une conteuse professionnelle elle était
à la médiathèque anatole-france de
trappes mélanie poquet pour ce reportage
tout à fait au début du monde il n'y
avait rien c'était noir tout noir
infiniment noir juste un oeuf le pays du
soleil levant
au coeur du récit conté la médiathèque
anatole-france et transporté en chine au
son de la voix de nathalie leone comptes
associés de cette 16e édition de la fête
du conte a explosé quand il rentre dans
le rêve qui est sûre j'ai simplement par
les mots l'atmosphère d'un compteur ils
sont eux mêmes très surpris parce que
qu'est ce qui se passe ce rêve c'est pas
quelque chose qu'ils ont sur un écran
c'est pas des images imposé c'est leur
image propre il crée à moitié
le conte en et co-créateur des comptes
avec les enfants et les adultes et cette
participation de leur imaginaire propre
à l'histoire ça les émeut profondément
essayé remplaçable cette année le temps
est au coeur du récit
cet instant suspens où les enfants
peuvent voyager et rêver les plus jeunes
mais pas seulement
ça nous fait rêver un peu
et puis ça nous rappelle
les histoires qu'on lisait autrefois et
puis que je livre mon petit fils on
revient à l'époque où les comptes
étaient plus important est donc très
agréable à écouter et la participation
l'imagination de chacun qui se développe
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien j'ai pas vu
bien passé jusqu'au 10 décembre les sept
médiathèques saint-quentinoise et le
bibliobus vivre au fil des histoires
racontées par des artistes un autre
univers à présent le battle be the one
va se dérouler le samedi 3 décembre à
15h30 à la salle culturelle de la merise
attrape plusieurs compétitions sont à
prévoir pour ce battle le public va
pouvoir assister à des démonstrations de
break dance ou encore à de krump
plusieurs yvelinois ils participent dont
un certain bambino la rencontre est
signé haussmann vendeurs des et nicolas
landry
c'est l'un des meilleurs danseurs des
yvelines il s'appelle bambino il nous
vient de trappes
ce danseur qui est tombé dans la culture
hip hop il y à 12 ans bien prendre sa
revanche lors de cette deuxième édition
du battle bin jawwad attrape des bons
retours
on a tardé au premier tour mais en fait
on a eu ex-aequo au début sa liste
égalité et il y avait un passage
supplémentaire et à prendre un jet c'est
pas ça chez commentaire
et pour cette deuxième édition le
trappistes va danser avec son binôme a
dès qu'il parcourt la france depuis cinq
ans et pour remporter le battle qu'ils
ont un plan non n'est pas techniquement
on était sur le ressenti de la musique
c'est à dire va pisser l'essai s'est
laissé aller par rapport à la musique et
on va essayer de prendre la musique et
de montrer ce que l'on sait faire
notre style à nous par rapport à la
musique c'est ça c'est de l'impro il ya
beaucoup de nous on est plus sur le free
style comme on dit on est plus en
retrait style lyonnaises ont des
passages préparé mais nous on est plus
triste elle préfère et on a des petits
trucs à nous les petits on va dire des
petites phases qui sont à nous qu'on
connaît qu'on va les sortir mais sinon
et beaucoup triste et bambino s'entraîne
tous les jours pour la deuxième édition
du battle be the one
le battle se déroule le samedi 3
décembre à 15 heures 30 à la halle
culturel de la merise attrape les
vainqueurs remporteront 200 euros
[Musique]
et bonne chance forcément fin du journal
demain vendredi vous avez rendez vous
avec nicolas quere lovitz pour un 7 8
hebdo consacre est en très grande partie
à la nouvelle édition du téléthon très
bonne soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]